last question
i sometimes ask this just for to uh
what is it to challenge to make people
roll their eyes
to make legitimate scientists roll their
eyes ask
what is the meaning of life according to
joe rogan i do not think there is a
meaning
i think there's many many meanings of
life i think there's a way to navigate
life that's enjoyable
i think it requires many things it
requires first of all requires
love you have to have loved ones you
have to have family
you have to have friends you have to
have people that care about you
and you have to care about them i think
that is primary
then it also requires interests
there has to be things that stimulate
you now it could be just a subsistence
lifestyle there's many people that
believe
and practice this uh lifestyle of just
living off the land and hunting and
fishing and living in the woods
and they seem incredibly happy yeah and
there's there's something to be said for
that
that is an interest right there's
something and there's a there's a
direct connection between their actions
and their sustenance
they get their food that way they're
connected to nature and it's very
satisfying for them
if you don't have that uh i think you
need something that
is interesting to you something that
you're passionate about
and there's far too many people that get
sucked into living a life where
you're just doing a job you're just
showing up and putting in your time and
then going home but you don't have a
passion
for what you're doing and i think that
is that's the recipe for a boring
and very unfulfilling life you mentioned
love difficulty
backtrack what uh we talked about the
demons and the violence
in there somewhere what's the role of
love in this
in your own life it's very important man
and that's one of the reasons why i'm so
uh i'm so interested in helping people
i'm very interested in people feeling
good
i like them to feel good i want to help
them i like i like doing things that
make them feel like oh you care about me
like yeah i care about you
i really do like i want people to feel
good i want
my family to feel good i want my friends
to feel good i want guests to feel
good about the podcast experience you
know i i
am i'm a big believer in as much as i
can to spread
positive energy and joy and happiness
and and relay all the good advice that
i've ever gotten
all the things that i've learned and if
they can benefit people and i find that
those things benefit people
that actually improve the quality of
their life or improve their success
or improve their relationships or i'm
very happy to do that
that means a lot to me the the way we
interact with each other
is so important it's one of the reasons
why like
if someone gets cancelled or you get
publicly shamed it's so devastating
because there's all these people that
negative all this negative energy coming
your way and you feel it as much as you
like to pretend
that you you're immune to that kind of
stuff and some people do like to pretend
that
you feel it there's a there's a tangible
force when people are upset at you
and that's the same with loved ones or
family or
anytime someone's upset at you whether
it's a giant group of people
or there's a small amount of people that
has an impact on you
and your psyche and your physical being
so the more
you can spread love and the more love
comes back to you you
also create this butterfly effect right
because where
other people start recognizing like oh
you know when he is nice to me
i feel better and then i'm going to be
nicer to people and when i'm nicer to
people they feel better and i feel
better
and it spreads outward and that's one
thing that i've done through this
podcast i think is i've
i've imparted my personal philosophy on
in in kindness and generosity to other
people yeah i mean
to correct you you didn't do it the
ideas that are breeding themselves
through your brain have figured out the
ideas
that are alive in the air made their way
into my head
love is a more efficient mechanism of
spreading ideas they figured out
yes probably man
probably um so as far as like uh
the meaning of life that's that's a bit
without that you have nothing
you know one of the big biggest failures
in life is to be extremely successful
financially but everybody hates you
everybody hates you and you're just
miserable and alone and angry and
depressed and sad
you know when you you hear about rich
famous people that commit suicide
wow you missed the mark you got
some parts right but you put too many
eggs in one basket
you put too many eggs in the financial
basket or the success basket or the
accomplishment basket
and not enough in the friendship and
love basket and there's a balance to
that
and when i talked about the violence and
all that stuff like
that to me is me understanding
recognizing that is me trying to achieve
that balance
it's so like go kill those demons so
that this boat is level
you know because if it's not then the
boat is like this and then everything's
all [ __ ] up and every time we hit a
wave things fall
apart balance that boat out figure it
out like
know who you are some people don't have
that problem at all
some people they could just go for walks
and they're cool as a cucumber
i need more you know i need kettlebells
i need a heavy bag
i need uh i need the echo bike you know
air assault bike
i need some hardcore [ __ ] and if i don't
get that i don't feel good
so i figured that out too and that makes
me a nicer person and that makes my
interactions nicer it makes
it it changes the quality of my my
friendships and my relationships with
people i think
uh we mentioned eurolink i can
i can certainly uh guarantee that this
is one of the memories i'll be replaying
20 30 years from now once we get the
feature ready joe it's a huge honor to
talk to you i hope it's an honor to talk
to you too
dude i just came down here for this the
first week of
me doing this here and it's uh it's it's
very cool to have you always
i hope you make uh texas cool again and
uh
and and uh do your podcast another 10 11
whatever however many years
you're still on this earth all right
thank you brother appreciate you man
you